好的,谢谢大家
我上周其实稍微有点感冒
然后准备的时间稍微晚了一点
然后这样
上一周市场主要的变化还是跟
再上一周其实非常相似的
我们看到在宏观层面上
宏观在驱动整个市场的变化
宏观也在驱动比方说股票之类的这些风险自然变化
那么最大的宏观的变化
就是宏观的持续性还是在利率和外汇上面
就是我们再上一周看到的Dollar美元利率的走枪
美元利率往上走
然后美元的走枪这两件事情再继续在同时发生
所以一般我们在讲就是
Rate Steepin就是利率变斗
然后利率上行
加上美元如果走枪
这两件事情同时发生的话
风险资产是一个通上
特别是当这个利率走的速度很快的时候
那么对风险资产的杀伤就会更加大
那么这个我们在昨天市场
在前几天市场
因为其实S&P从Top Down现在下来5个点不到
三四个点
下来的中间很大原因就是宏观被带断
那么宏观背后是什么东西呢
其实就是大家重新定义
有这个美国利率
那么在重新定义美国利率的时候
也在重新定义美国的汇率
上周五的时候
上周其实上周三有ADP
然后上周五的话有Nomfong Payroll
那这个Nomfong Payroll是非常重要的这个就业的数据
那么我们看到美国经济非常好
其实美国经济的情况跟我们之前预测半年以内吧
就过去半年一直说的这个美国经济没有问题
基本面还是很强
基本上是Line相同的
也就是说市场重新开始Pricing了
就说美国经济其实没有一点走路的迹象
那这个经济非常好
包括上次FOMC的时候
那个Japow再说我们现在经济基本面非常好
那个似乎看上去
似乎看上去我们有很大的这个空间
那么市场就开始Pricing经济变好
然后FOMC会变得更加强硬
Nomfong Payroll来说的话
25万25.6万
这个数字可能之后会调整
那么25.6万这个数字是过了这个top line很多的
但是我们如果之前一直看这个Nomfong Payroll的话
我们会发现在疫情之后
这个就业的数据其实波动很大
也就是说它一般会在这个20万上下
就是原来是20万上下可能几万的规模在波动
现在在18万到20万上下
可能在这个5万到10万的这个规模在波动
所以它往上的波动也会往下波动
这个这个但是至少来看trend来看
去世来看美国经济确实没有问题
N-imployment数据
失业率的数据下降了50
15个basis.4.1
我要这里好像没有花进去4.1
那么从job growth和job opening
就是那个招工的数据
我们星期二的时候看到招工的数据
job opening的数据看上去经济都是非常好
那么回到我我对于25年的这个经济基本面预测
就是回到我们上周讲过的一个就是这个tell risk的问题
就从那个baseline来说
就是tell risk就是基本基本的基本基本的看法
来说美国经济继续会走架
但是市场也在pricing很多的这个tell
极端的风险
极端的风险呢
我个人觉得不在现在
那极端风险更多在那个特朗普要当选之后
他的一些经济政策
包括的他的这个就DOG1
削减赤字
这个东西怎么执行
移民还有关税
看这三个东西最后会对美国造成什么样的影响
但是不像是现在
现在更多的是向反向的就是对联储政策的这个定义
也就是说我们之前经历过叫bad news
那又是good news
当经济数据不好的时候
然后呢我们觉得美联储会降息
然后反而涨一波
这样的上涨基本上都会回土的
因为最终当经济变得不好的时候
那么这个故事是要掉下去了
那个我觉得现在是向反
也就是说现在是good news的bad news
之前市场太早开始定价
特别是特朗普当选之后
太早开始定价
经济已经开始恢复了
那么
但是森浩在定价经济恢复
同时他没有定价
利率是会利率是会上升的
也就是说降息是会变还的
那这个事情没有定价
所以当我们现在看到经济实在太好的时候
觉得美联储不会做什么
那么就重新开始定价
利率的这个利率的会恢复
那么这个过程中间叫做good news
等于bad news
但是这个事情是要补扰
因为经济好意味着我们应该是13号开始
就是就接下去13号是4号吧
就这几天美国开始要抱一季度的
四季度的这个业绩
因为四季度其实基本面很好了
就我觉得四季度大概日的业绩也会不错
就是最终经济好是带同公司业绩
公司业绩是会带等东西上涨的
我们可以看得到是在过去几个月里面
或者说当利率上升的时候
什么样的公司是真正受到影响
这个是狗们的一个高尚的一个指数
就是没有盈利的
就是没有盈利的科技公司
这个下面是有盈利的公司
所以你会看到在过去
你说长洲期来说
虽然当利率上升的时候
普遍来说股票是要跌
对吧
但是我们看到特别是疫情之后
二二年疫情之后
利率上升的时候
意味着经济基本面好
所以大致的趋势和盈利公司是一致的
就说基本面好经济利率上升
然后那些Mega 7
这些盈利好的公司
它反而会上
真正跌下来的
就是反向走的
像现在反向走
跌下来是不盈利的公司
不盈利的公司
同时的话
也会说是比方说一些流动性的资产
比方说比特币
比方说黄金
那这些东西
在BSD本加上Dollar rate走墙
这个过程中间
他们可能是撑不住的
不太好撑
不好意思
我稍微有点感冒
声音不太好
所以这些资产是比较难以撑得住的
那么这一周市场
主要关注的经济数据的焦点
还在CPI上面
我个人觉得
现在美国的
我个人的判断
现在美国的经济是很好
然后通胀相反还是可控的
并不是处于一个
比方说去年3月份这种
通胀数据会往上飙升
所以美联储很有可能的政策
它只是不急于去扯
不急于去降息
它的在经济变好
然后通胀可控情况下
它现在有更多的余地
去观察
特朗普的关税政策
可能会对通胀造成的影响
所以确实3月份不太会降息的
3月份不降息之后
很有可能会拖到6月份
或者是7月份去降息
市场现在对于
连储降息的定价
基本是在
因为交易一直在fratiate
就在再来回
所以交易基本是在0.5 basis point
一个cut以内
对于大概在0.5 basis point
那么在这样的一个定价的情况下
我觉得利率其实有一点 overpriced
当然这是10年期利率
10年期利率我结了一下
这是最高的时候 4.8
昨天晚上确定的时候
利率已经下来一些了
但是4.8的10年期利率
已经是非常好
那么这个利率中间
我们会回顾一下
过去3个月的市场首饰
过去3个月是股票在涨
利率在涨
然后美元在涨
中间的集合的判断其实是有分歧的
就是说利率上升的时候
利率上升 股上升
最后的price是
经济基本面会非常好
然后加上policy deregulation
那么这几个东西去结合在一起
那么现在股市上没有一个反
就是有一个重新的self
本质上是对于利率和美元
涨了实在太多的一个反馈
这三件事情一起发生的时候
股市最终是对利率和美元进行反馈
就说我重新要self
但是也是一次再次的确认
就是我最终还是要确认
美国经济增长
或者是大家全球继续配置
大规模配置美元资产的趋势
会不会结束
我个人感觉在
如果不出tell risk
不出这个黑天鹅的话
那么这个东西不太会结束
美国现在集合几件事情
一个是科技
然后AI基本都在美国
考的科技公司
盈利科技公司都在美国
然后科技公司重新进行投资
比方说在云场
必须去投云的产力
也是在美国
美国的physical policy
很有可能
就是我们有两种概率
就有30%的概率
说特朗普真的去大规模的检制
字 人都看掉
那么这个事情如果发生的话
确实会造成中险
但是很有可能
像白奥森现在的政策
他因为他选财长
很大程度上去
就看着他的政策的表现
那同时的话
他在 budget deficit
就是debt ceiling
突破债务上限的过程中
跟共和党党内也有很多的
来来回回的
并值的博弈
那么在突破债务上限的时候
是讲的是1.2个
就是1.2个缺点
就是突破1.2个
可以增加1.2个缺点
但是在未来10年里面
把赤字减少
2.5个缺点
那么这个过程
其实把它拉了很长
其实代表的有可能
看完普遍
没有那么积极的要去减赤字
这我现在是越来越觉得
特朗普可能
但这个要看他最后政策
可能没有那么积极去减赤字
那么
所以大概率的情况下
我们说basic is
很有可能就是赤字的政策
或者就是美国财政赤字的政策
还是会延续
那么第三就是
FAT
虽然我们会看到它现在
相对来说比较强硬
但是它对于上行风险
和下行风险实施的时候
它的政策的偏离都是不一样的
每一次当经济变得不好的时候
它会非常快的去降息
包括上一次
8月份的时候
它非常积极的去降息
但是经济变好
或者通胀上行的时候
它深吸或者是它变
变阴的速度比它变割的速度要慢
相对来说还是会慢很多的
所以FAT更多的是
是bias的
是偏离
它的屁股是坐在鸽派上面
或者美联储对于整个市场是有一个put
这三个原因
再加上美国特朗普比较明确的
包括他后面的背后的团队
伊隆或者是Peter Thiel
他们是比较明确的
是要deregulation去做去监管这过程
所以在这几个因素
四个因素的联合在作用下面
就是对于美国来说
美国的投资
资金流露美国的趋势
从2023年开始其实没有变化
也就是说我们可以看到过去
比方说08年15年以前
资金怎么流露中国的
现代资金就是怎么流露美国的
Trend是一个很长期的程
我不觉得它解锁
不好意思
我两个头发里放的是一样
然后同时的话
我们看到美国的divergence
和其他国家经济的区别也在拉档
疫情之前是蓝颜色的线
就是我们的增长它是蓝颜色的线
但是疫情之后
现在你可以看到
其实是美国和日本对于中国和欧洲
那么divergence这个分歧会非常明显
美国和日本是货币政策
在追它的增长或者是通胀
你就是说日本在通胀
它增长也很好
然后美国增长很好
它可能没有通胀
但是monitory policy
它的美联储和boj
他们的政策其实现在相对来说
还是落后于它的经济增长
在这个过程中间
它会有很多的反复
因为大家怕它升息
怕它美国将细架了慢
会有很多的反复
但是基本上市场是往上的
因为政策不会
就是刚刚我讲的美联储政策
其实任何央行的政策
它屁股都是坐在鸽派那边的
相对来说它没有那么的强硬
强硬的速度会比经济增长
或者是通胀要慢
它追着政策
所以经济
我是觉得股票市场或者风险资产市场
它是要往上涨的这个趋势
那么中国和欧洲是财政政策在追通
说财政政策受到很多的制约的
欧洲比方说有很多的
有本身有法律
包括有欧元区的一些规定
它的财政政策
不能超过一定的上限
中国不知道为什么
财政政策其实一直紧扣扣的
就是因为财政收入比较低
国家还要做些其他的事情
所以财政政策去补充这个通缩
或者是弥补通缩
这过程中间它比通缩要慢
所以它这个过程中间
欧洲和中国的资产是不能持有的
或者说它每次政策出来
你可以去炒一波
然后要快点逃跑
所以这个市场的divergence
那个我觉得还是会继续
什么美元资产的配置在baseline里面
我觉得是没有什么特别大的问题
那话说回来
就说这个长端率率怎么看
就我现在觉得长端率现在 overpriced
就是一个总结
就是说长端率率现在已经过分了
我在过去一年
一年多吧
我一直是看长端率率很难下来
然后会继续上行
那我其实在去年二三月份的时候
就是觉得到时候说了这样些
我一直觉得长端率率应该在7.5
那么我现在觉得长端率率也应该是7.5
7.5到7
不7.5 sorry
4.5
在4.5到4.7之间
那么这个是一个合理的底下去见
那么不是说现在这个到4.8
或者甚至可能跑到比4.8更高
不可能
就是说你当你定价偏离了
这个偏离了这个定价区间的情况下
他很有可能还会继续上行
但是利率本身是有min reversion
就是他有这个有有发就长上
长大学他会回来的
他有一个有一个中间纸会来回波动了
那同时的话呢
就说你不能定价他去升息吧
美联储虽然说他降息的幅度可能会变慢
去明年就今年的话
大家有争议是降一次还增加两次
我觉得很有可能还是会加两次
两次不排除的
那至少是
至少是他不会去升息
现在市场已经定价到0.5个Base point
就预期的话0.5个Base point
债券的空头继续把那个债券打下去
他这个空间其实是有限的
当你空间有限的时候
那么就会有更多人去抄底
因为债券你不能打得太过分
所以虽然说
而且从第三个原因
从供应面来说
2025年的供应面比2024年好那么一丢丢
那我这个事情我上周可能也说过
所以在这个几个因素结合上来想的话呢
我觉得1月份现在的这个rate move
已经有点过分了
所以不排除他可能在1月底接下去
一段时间继续往上跑一跑和冲一冲
哪怕或者是明天
这个我对数据完全没有100%的确定性
比方说CPR数据如果变差
他利率继续往上走
我觉得不排除这个可能性
但是即使CPR数据变差
就是CPR数据高往上走
他的利率现在的定价还是过高
就是我们不能说真的pricing
就是2025年他要升息
那么除非tariff做了非常非常积极
或者非常过分
我觉得这可能也没有很强很大
现在很多的政策看上去
测浪谱他的各方面政策
都有一种就是雷声大雨点小的感觉
这可能不小
所以我们可以继续观察
但是观察意味着就是你的仓位
可能不应当非常高
因为毕竟是有很多的tel risk在
那么但是的话呢
我我会觉得就是说
现在利率水平现在偏高
所以在非常短期里面
就是我们可能看到二月份吧
或者是短谱上台以后
我们会看一轮反弹
就是对于现在市场的一轮反弹
这轮反弹不代表的
我们的tel risk已经结束了
我们就好像开车进路
因为今天我早上跟一个朋友
在说这个事情
就好像我们开车进路
一个比较宁宁有坑坑挖挖的这个地上
所以第一个坑可能我不觉得没有很大
但是确实应该减速
因为后面会有各种这样的不确定性和坑
但是就目前看到对FOMC的事情
对于美国降息的这个降息重新定价
我觉得第一个呢
利率上定价是过分的
然后第二呢
即使利率定价是没错的话
后面意味着后面经济增长很好
经济增长很好的话
整个资本市场还是要拉回来的
所以我不对
我不觉得这一轮的重新定价危险很大
那么但是呢
我觉得二月份以后
特朗普上台以后的政策和经济基本面的定价
是要重新去观察的
真正大的风险是在经济基本面变弱
还不是经济基本面变强
经济基本面变弱的时候
大家会pricing这个fab cut
就是bad news等于good news
这种情况下呢
一般是要补贴的
我们现在就刚刚我讲
我们现在可能是反过来
那么最后说一下
就是我对于利率
因为大家很多有很多问题
关于利率和利率对于后面市场的影响
我觉得是这样
就是一般来说
你会看到最后这一端的这个利率上行
一般来说利率是看绝对水平的
他不是看我到了4.5
还是到了比方说到了5
到了5我就利率
我到了5就那个股票涨不动了
不存在
我刚刚就讲
这个是大盘
这个是主要盈利的公司
他完全是可以跟着利率一起走
那个盈利公司利率好的时候经济好
所以他一起上涨
一起下电账很正常
跟以前我们在疫情以前
大家都比较熟悉的respect
就是比方说股债不同步
然后我配股配债
这个逻辑在疫情之后完全打跑
不存在这样的附近
那但是利率快速的上升
是会对市场造成很负面意见
也就是说我们以前做过一个统计
看到利率如果是走了比方说
两个standard deviation
说他的他的就是走了两个房产
就是我们叫极度的移动了
这个5%
两个standard deviation就是5%
统计上5%
如果移动了统计上的5%
那么必然会对资本市场造成冲击
冲击最大的是比较说流动型资产
黄金 比特利
或者是没有盈利的那些公司
冲击相对比较小的是有盈利的公司
但是确实就是我们不用去观察
利率本身的价位
而是要去看利率移动的速度
那么这一轮的速度非常快
所以它确实对市场造成影响
但是它能不能在这个速度上面
继续上架
那个我觉得不行
就很难
那么其实这个网上和网下是一样的
网下很快的速度一般伴随着
它在暴跌的时候
利率会很快的往下跑
但是往下很快跑完以后
它也会导致股票的迷你
然后市场上一般会讲
联署要降息了
然后利率很低联署要降息了
所以我们可以观察一下它的速度
所以这个是我对利率对市场影响
最后还有一个
就是最后还有一个就是汇率
我这一考相忘记花汇率的图了
那我就用利率继续讲一下汇率
其实汇率很大
神舟上这一轮是被利率推动的
但是利率有一个本质的不同
汇率现在我觉得没有过分的定价
利率过分定价中间有
说连储不能降息
不不可能去升息
而且在去年这么大的供应量的情况下
其实长端利率已经到了一个比较高的水平了
但是汇率我觉得还没有完全pricing
美元走墙
美元走墙会是今年大跌掉
这个走墙是本质上是美国经济对于
全球其他国家经济的一个divorence
一个分离
就是它的经济很好
它的科技发展也很好
它的股票市场也很好
钱也会到他那里去
当然这都是base case
如果他狼谱真的拼命搞DOG1的话
那是两回事件
所以这个是市场大的趋势
那么美元走墙
它是对于欧元走墙
可能对于日元走墙
也会对于人民币走墙
这个趋势我觉得不太会变化
也就是说今年我们会很快的看到欧元破壹
而且会在破壹的情况下
维持一段时间
至少是今年
我觉得基本大击掉欧元是要破壹的
这个背后就是我们现在越来越清楚的
美国利率政策和欧洲的利率政策的分歧
或者是跟中国也有同样的分歧
就我们刚刚讲
一个是央行在追经济
一个是财政部在追经济
就是财政部的使用权用权
我们叫physical policy在追经济
在追通缩
这个两个区别会导致整个美元
在一个很长的入期里面去走墙
real money的重新
重新hatch
就是hatch美元走墙的风险
或者是他放开美元走墙的场口
希望得到美元
这个趋势也是比较明显
就是我我我赚了钱
我宁可放在美元里
所以我觉得利率的定价
就是差不多到头
但是美元定价的在现在才刚刚开始
我们会看到更多更强的美元
那么特别是美元对于人民币的定价
我觉得现在还没有完全反映
就是现在在4点3
很有可能会报到7点3
很有可能在控制的情况下
跑到7.5去
这个在Trump policy不来以后
我觉得很有可能就会出来
那么中国人民币的政策
我觉得他一直会憋住
然后直接等到在一个
他守不住的时候把他放开
但是这个不太像是今年
这个毕竟还是这个中国的一个脸面
然后人民币现在
人民币如果现在大规模的走墙
其实也不符合中国的利益
那么中国有很多的产业
其实已经搬到了境外去了
那个包括我们要做很多的进口
其实你想中国是这样的
中国的进口都是国企做的
然后中国的出口
很多都是民企或者是合资企业做的
那么在这个经济螺旋中间的
就是说你想政府的屁股
他是照顾养子
还是照顾亲儿子
那肯定是照顾亲儿子
那么包括有很多的这个产业
其实搬到境外去
那么人民币的这个汇率的政策
他会改变
包括他大规模把人民币贬值
还会导致美国的一些报复
特朗普的这个制裁商的报复
所以他会尽量守
守到他守不住
所以我们看到去年
比方说5000亿的贸易
那么这个贸易的顺差
并没有增加我们的外汇储备
那个也没有增加
其实没有增加我们美国国债
所以这个里面就是我们拿钱
继续去守
那么人民币我觉得他守在现在7.3
7.2那比较难
他最后可能会守在7.5
7.4到7.5之前
或者在这个位置上去守
但是终究他的换汇的政策
会越变越严格
这个我觉得是会见
那么在你不知道的可能
会在明年或者可能会在
接下去一年
或者是二五年一年两年
或者这个时间不确定的时候
他最终会有个时间点
他守不住了
那么就会很有可能会打开人民币
那么这个时候就要看他美元
是不是继续在走向中期
然后再决定
人民币会跑到一个什么样的位置去
好吧
我大概还是利率和外汇
就是市场的这个主旋律
那么我们明天
后天
亚洲时间应该是后天
关注一下最后CPI的一个情况
我个人觉得基本上还是会阴谋Focus
看到CPI有很多
因为3月份的CPI
去年3月份的CPI
有很多智厚的因素导致CPI上升
那么这些智厚因素其实现在都没有
我不觉得因为经济变强
它CPI会变得很高
或者超出很多
我觉得不太会
所以还是保持整体
对于延续性的经济数据和
这个经济数据和经济运行状况
我还是保持非常的乐观
我唯一不乐观的是
新的政策引起的
可能的经济基本面表
那这个要到川普上台以后再看
好
那看看大家有什么问题